hi I'm Erik Bosse and adventures in game
released a full deleted scene with Iron
Man Tony Stark's heartbreaking sacrifice
at the end of the film having a new
previously unseen fallout a fallout that
would have given deeper insight to each
of the surviving Avengers mindsets shed
light on mysteries from the end of the
film and made a few people look like
real dicks the scene actually has a lot
of cool details that you might have
overlooked so let's break them all down
and discuss why the scene was removed
and how its inclusion would have changed
the in-game ending and look at what
takeaways this deleted scene gives us
with regard to the future destinies of
other MCU heroes boiler warning I guess
if any of this speculation gives you too
much insight okay let's take a look at
this deleted footage so this is after
Pepper Potts kisses the recently passed
Tony and in the original code we see
Captain Thor watching on sadly but
instead of just panning past Starks face
and fading to black in this deleted
scene we cut to a reaction that was
removed from the final cut Hawkeye
Clint Barton who pulls a Kaepernick and
starts a kneeling trend in a theatrical
release version most of the characters
closest to Tony do get personal goodbyes
or reaction shots Rhodey Peter Parker
Pepper and that reaction shot of cap and
Thor but this deleted scene shares that
grief with the often overlooked og
Avenger Hawkeye now Bruce Banner Hulk is
in the scene if you look closely he's
only featured in the margin of the final
angle of the deleted scene because his
effects were still unfinished and yeah
it would take away from this moment to
cut to a potato II n64 graphics Hulk or
even worse Mark Ruffalo in his goofy
mocap unitard with that dumb eyeline
stick over his head
oh no Tony's dead I'm just gonna riding
up on me dude ruin the movie a couple of
interesting things to point out about
this opening shot notice how behind
Hawkeye is Thor's hammer Stormbreaker
left unattended and strewn on the ground
now of course this battle has been won
no need to continue to wield
Stormbreaker this means Thor presumably
dropped it in shock at scene stark this
way for a moment he has relinquished his
ego about being the strongest Avenger
because another Avenger has clearly
claimed that title for this moment
it's also worth noting the initial
kneeling order if you think about it
it kind of parallels the order of
possession of Starks Infinity Gauntlet
during the rugby style drive during the
final battle remember that started with
Hawkeye and then he handed it off to
Black Panther
and then he actually hit it off to
spider-man but he already got his
goodbye in the scene so the next one we
see is the final possessor before
thanasis starts final exchange Captain
Marvel so the order in which they pay
respects kind of matches the order in
which they assisted start to make this
final ultimate sacrifice now it's
interesting to think about Peter Quill's
thought process here um I guess I should
just kneel too but if you think about it
from his perspective Tony Stark was an
earthbound Avenger whom he fought
alongside on Titan in his most previous
memory of Stark was quills moment of
panic upon realizing he was dusting away
and what it starts saying to try to
comfort him still equal and now quill
only knows that he was brought back
right after this and that his return was
at the direct expense of Starks exchange
of life so I'm sure the words steady
quill will continue to have meaning to
him now nebula is next to Neal and
similarly she spent quite a bit of time
with stark on board the Benatar as it
drifted into space in their game of
folded football nebula scored her first
ever win in anything and later she
tucked in stark as he was drifting away
so her Neal here after joining the
Avengers any victory brings her kind of
full circle with those opening moments
now Valkyrie Neal's - cuz I'm sure she's
like I don't know who this guy is but I
don't wanna be a dick Scott Lang Neal's
his eyes filled with tears cap Neal's as
well he stumbles a bit showing his
physical exhaustion because this is
truly both his and Tony's final battle
and then what are more interesting
reactions Doctor Strange now his
behavior with Tony Stark was always a
bit aloof throughout infinity war in an
end game at first in the in-game final
battle he refused to confirm to start
whether this indeed was the one out of
14 million 6005 alternate futures in
which they were victorious until later
in the most crucial moment he finally
held up one finger to signify that it
was and now Strange's reaction humanizes
this sorcerer supreme you can see the
guilt in his eyes for kind of
manipulating this man into making the
ultimate sacrifice play because Strange
knew from that moment on Titan that that
was the only way that they could win and
looking back to that infinity war scene
you can see that strange was already
feeling mourning for Stark when he told
them won and later when he said I'm
sorry okay I know we're feeling the
feels of this moment but I just really
Kimora's like okay you Asgardians could
take a knee but i walked into the wrong
funeral home and i got places to be
oops sorry didn't mean to trip on you
Howard the Duck I'm not kneeling I'm
just short ducks ain't got kneecaps
stupid but this makes sense for Gomorrah
this Gomorrah is from 2014 she only
recently decided to betray Thanos she
doesn't know any of these folks other
than nebula and she's also right not to
trust them just yet because who knows
which of these grieving strangers might
hold her responsible for aiding and
abetting the conquerors who killed their
friends this also sheds a bit of light
on gomorrah's fate at the end of the
endgame now previously we just know she
was listed as missing when Peter quill
was looking for her at the end on the
benatar now we know for sure that Starks
final snap did indeed spare her and she
probably feels like she's been given a
bit of a second chance and she's now on
some new lonely path now the final shot
of this scene shows kneeling from Falcon
wandah Okoye a Drax Bucky and Sheree and
I love the cherries wearing some what
are those leeks and mantis takes forever
to kneel she looks around confused for
several seconds hilarious
hope Van Dyne and Wong are visible as
well rody is turned away in grief unable
to look at Stark and in 64 banner Hulk
is hiding behind some rubble and shame
over his unfinished VFX and we fade to
black so why was this scene removed well
according to a statement from the
directors Joe and Anthony Russo it was a
beautiful scene with moving performances
but we filmed it prior to Tony Stark's
funeral the funeral scene ultimately
became a more resonant and emotional
reflection on Tony's death for us
yeah if both this scene plus the long
tracking shot showing each MCU character
one by one were included it might have
felt a bit excessive like you could
definitely imagine Tony Stark's ghost
rolling his eyes and quipping guys come
on you can't give me two funerals and
black widow none do you think this scene
should have been included in the
theatrical cut of Avengers endgame
comment down below with your thoughts
and follow me on instagram and twitter
at a vos and subscribe to new rock stars
for breakdowns and theories about
everything marvel thank you for joining
me and hey how many subscribers do you
think we lost to that Kapernick bit
[Music]